on a peut-être un nouvel allié de
prestige si cette personne accepte de
devenir entre conseillers on peut
atteindre le trône de fer
mais qui est cette personne allez mr sa
maman c'est le fils maudit de la maison
des biens tout le monde le cherche dans
la capitale pour le but et comme pour
lui donner des gâteaux seuil aurel qui
leur est reconnu dans une taverne y aura
les ramènent plein de trucs des tavernes
la bouche des maladies d
[Musique]
voici lors de peter falk qui aurait
perdu son argent aux jeux histoires
simples efficaces génère non mais tout
est vrai c'est excellent on vous a
reconnu faut lire entre les lignes les
mystères sont le gers connu je suis
hyper physionomiste je suis pas de mac
os qu'elle y pense
je leur ai dit et m'ont donné ça échange
de conseils pour avoir le trône
je suis resté on est nuls en complot une
fois j'ai essayé d'en l'échafaud d1
c'était la cata fallait tuer le roi
déguisé en prostituées ou tué une
prostituée déguisés en rois où tu es le
roi déguisé en gigot on a besoin de
peter faut toujours être là où vous
attentats voyez moi par exemple ma
spécialité c'est le combat à mains nues
75 combat 76 cas où vous avez mis avec
eux aux deux fois dans un même combat
bon pour commencer faudrait penser à
changer votre emblème il n'est pas assez
bien à ce moment là mais ça vous avez
raison parce que l'emblème c'est
vraiment important parce que par exemple
le lion c'est royal
le ser ces majestueux et le dragon c'est
flippant
c'est juste liban ils sont mettez une
boulette ou une jatte à drapeau avec une
chatte dessus je dis n'importe quoi
freestyle
et ils m'adorent tous le monde les aime
bien mais moi j'ai plus envie de le
vendre pour moi ce que je vois c'est un
mètre vingt de traître à la couronne
j'ai envoyé un corbeau la capitale on a
reçu des messages indiquant la même
personne à deux endroits différents donc
je suis venu vérifier non c'est pas lui
vous aurez pas l'argent voilà c'était
une mission assez courte wow quel argent
il dit n'importe quoi tu as essayé de le
vendre on va pas se battre à suivre m
n'a pas pas tout le côté et c'était pas
du tout lui
je suis certain qu'on peut atteindre le
trône de fer a juste trouvé la petite
astuce qui nous permettraient de
survoler pouvoir des sept familles sont
prêtes à tout pour atteindre le trône de
fer avant nous faut penser malin
[Musique]
il